so i think the passion at least you know
from a personal point of view
is uh actually just curiosity of knowing
and learning new market
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford very excited to introduce you
to today's guest
yuval kohan founder and managing partner
at stage one ventures
yuval cohen is the founder and managing
partner at stage one ventures
leading investments across multiple
investment sectors
he has a track record of two decades in
leading the operations of early stage
vcs
before founding stage one he co-founded
and managed two corporate vcs as part of
idb
israel's largest conglomerate estimated
at 150 million dollars in the investment
portfolio
and was personally involved in early
stage it investing totaling over one
billion dollars in exit value uval
currently represents stage one on
several company boards
including autonomous silver fort epsigon
theater
common ground model 9 and cover you
valcoin
welcome to 20 minute leaders all the way
from tel aviv
stage 1 vc how are you i'm great
i'm great here it is
yes yes i hopefully you know we'll soon
get everybody to that
to that level but right now um we can
talk about you know quran and all that
stuff but what i really want to focus on
is your journey
and you know one of the top investors in
israel stage one vc one of the top vc
firms in israel
and um you know just from starting to
take a look
at the different initiatives you've been
a part of and the different
you know vcs that you've that you've
been a part of this is not the first one
you've had quite a few
beforehand and i i'm insanely curious
to pick your brain and go in there
and start understanding you know how how
your thought process works
where did you start from why do you
decide to become an investor and how do
you go about
you know your day by day figuring out
how to back the best and the brightest
in in the in the best industries as well
so yuval take me back
why why become an investor what what
what was the plan on becoming a vc
frankly there was no plan so basically
i uh i grew up in france in paris
came to israel just before my military
service spent
about five years with the idea and uh
and then after uh studying in the hebrew
university of jerusalem
i did a kind of a mix of of law school
uh
and an mba in corporate finance and uh
i found you know i found myself almost
by mistake
in uh one of israel's largest
conglomerates
at that time idv and i joined the
buddy you skipped over something which
one
what what you you started out hellboy at
a hotel that's right i started as a
bellboy i mean just after coming to
israel i had the
few months before military service
and i wanted to earn some money i spent
about six months working as a
checker and bell boy in an hotel in
jerusalem
and believe me it's a kind of lesson for
life
i mean you see uh you see i mean
really uh interesting stories but anyway
it was a
pretty uh nice experience then i joined
the army as i said
what do you think from there to now i
pick that
and and i think that the lesson i mean
that actually
goes from from those days till today
that everything is about people i mean
it's all about people
when you look i mean the interaction i
mean between people is uh
both on a personal level and on the
business level
but you need to communicate and later on
i mean i'll tell you i mean why i
decided to focus on the siddha
stage because i think it's part of the
story
so anyway i started my career in idb
just
at that time i think one of the largest
groups in israel
if not the largest one and um
and almost by coincidence i joined the
capital i mean
i joined the capital market division and
i was very i was pretty fascinated by
public markets and option trading
and that's what uh we started back then
a mix of investment banking and and
kind of brokerage um
and all of a sudden i don't even
remember why but the market
crashed worldwide i want to believe it's
not because of me
but anyway what happened is that we had
i mean to reinvent ourselves at that
time
and it was you know the mid 90s
uh very few tech companies in israel
uh with i mean you might recall
eci scitex and those
giants yes most of the
tech by the way was telecom
oriented right and
we decided i mean we after a trip
to new york uh basically
i came back um we came back
and i remember i mean that the head of
the division i mean presented a
senior person that uh
spent several years in the bay area and
uh and he said i mean i mean this guy
will be
leading a kind of corporate fund uh
for uh idb by the way corporate fund i
mean it was
it was actually uh maybe one of the
first in the country
at that time and right um i teamed up
with two other partners
uh and we actually set
the first fund and then we set a second
fund
as part of idb um these were terrific
years i mean to invest in the
telecom sector and the enterprise
software in israel
for many for two reasons
i mean there was uh i mean just i know
six seven years before the the internet
boom
second a lot of knowledge that actually
basically it was more like military
knowledge that got
commercialized uh from the army
and went to different sectors right uh
and that's the story of the israeli
heights of course
um but anyway very at that point very
well
you know do you feel that you know
israel is going to become
the powerhouse that it is destined to
become is that
is that something you know in in the day
in the day-to-day of an investor in your
position
do you see that trajectory is that
obvious or is this something that
you know it wasn't that obvious to
happen uh it wasn't obvious at all
i mean uh i remember you know the first
founders i mean that
that we backed were
pure engineer
zero business experience and not only
zero business experience it was more you
know
no international experience at all uh
and
what happened is that uh luckily
and enough i mean we've been uh focusing
on on the deep deck i mean that you
mentioned at the very beginning
uh and this was actually a decision that
we took
after uh analyzing the market and seeing
i mean that
the major advantages of the israeli
ecosystem
are the technology the the manpower
the engineers i always say that by the
300 multinational companies that have
their
r d centers here in israel are looking
for the israeli engineer and not
necessarily the
israeli sensor marketing person
so and by the way it hasn't changed
since then
um that's uh and we decided to focus on
those sectors
uh we backed a bunch of uh pretty uh
successful companies um
funny enough the first one was pretty
successful
the second one was less successful um
and and the reason is that actually we
raised a much larger
fund the second one was much larger very
diversified we started investing in
in mid to late stages as well and
um and then after a period of seven
years
the idea i mean within the group was to
form a third fund it of course would be
larger
like most of the fans all over the world
uh
and for me it was a kind of red flag
at that time i felt pretty senior i just
crossed the 32
i was 32 at that time and i was
stupid enough to say okay let's
leave it and start and start basically a
kind of
boutique uh and that's how i teamed up
with the
with the founder that i backed several
years uh
before that uh it was a pretty
successful person at ramgash
um and together we started the stage one
um take me to that to that that day
so you know i i talked to a lot of start
founders talking about you know okay how
do you bring the team together how do
you come up with product market fit
you know it sounds to me that forming a
venture capital fund is not
that different you need the right team
you need
to find product market fit with your
thesis with
who to back and how to back them and how
to get you know the right deal flow and
at the end
you know you're talking about deep
technology you know the the the better
due diligence you do
the better your product will be the
better sort of you know quote-unquote
and you know returns will come to the
fun so share with me know
your your way you're sitting down with
a founder that you previously backed
what happens so
what happened i mean we said in a pretty
naive approach
we're gonna look at three major pillars
and i'll talk about these
those pillars later on and we're gonna
start a fund a small
small one basically that would
invest and follow these three major
pillars or guidelines
and we said okay if that's the case what
are we missing
it was pretty clear that i'm bringing
more in all the financial slash
business experience while uh my partner
was bringing more the
technical aspects and the network i
didn't serve in
served in 8200 so uh
he did um so
actually it was a good a good fit
and we decided to to start a fund that
basically would invest
in israel and israeli entrepreneurs so
in some cases these are israel
entrepreneurs that are
based in in the us that have the rng
center in israel
but in most cases this would be
companies here in israel
second we do seed only
i mean we start from really from the
very beginning i know that
many fans i mean talk about the early
stage every stage became a pretty
flexible
definition so for us means that
we i would say that in more than 90 i
know
of of our companies we are the first and
only check around the table
while most cases we actually register
the company together with the founders
so
that's how early well that's a real
that's amazing and uh and the third part
of the strategy was to be very focused
on what we called
b2b infrastructure so everything that
would go to the infrastructure of
medium to large enterprises was
i mean and it's still of interest to us
no bcc
no actually of course america
biotech i mean we invest in sectors that
we've known for many years uh under that
yeah
in umbrella i mean we started so far
three funds my
my initial partners actually left to run
one of our portfolio companies
back in 2000 actually six wow relocated
to the us with that company
[Music]
since then by the way he came back to
israel
and in 2013 dan slobotkin
joined me i mean i met tal while he was
representing
cisco in one of our
portfolio companies and that's how we
met i mean he represented cisco at that
time
and we failed i mean again that it's a
it's a good fit
uh by the way tal is younger than i
by more than 10 years so it's uh these
are the kind of
very different entrepreneurs that we are
approaching
before me right it's more like you know
second timers or sometimes even third
timers
um and bring and while tal brings more
you know the
the network from the army i mean after
spending more than 10 years
um in a very strong technical background
um yuval can you take me back to the
first
investment or one of the first
investments that you need to make as a
team
and i'm trying to picture you know this
new
venture fund forming you're forming it
with people that
not might not have necessarily you know
invested money in the past it's it's a
different you know
work work environment is it an easy
decision
like do you have to sort of convince
each other is it
you know everybody agrees or or maybe
one partner just really likes it and so
everybody just you know goes with the
flow
how do you define sort of the structure
under which
you agree as an investment committee to
go into a deal and i'm especially
curious about
you know the root of it you know how you
even form
the strategy of of coming up with this
method
so frankly since uh you know city
investing is pretty risky
and although we are we try to be very
focused on some sectors and we believe
we are pretty familiar with those
sectors uh
it's still pretty risky uh when we
invest
basically in two three founders with a
with a one pager in most cases um
and wow but it it was never
discussed you know on a formal slash
legal level
that we're gonna take a decision to a
unanimous vote but wow i don't know
why and how to explain it but as a fact
in in most case cases i mean we we
voted together and i always say i mean
is so risky that if one of the partners
feels i mean that we shouldn't do it so
let's
let's you know let's skip it i know that
there are different approaches by the
way
in much larger funds i know that in some
cases
uh some of the partners can take
a decision i mean it kind of majority
vote or something like that
for us i mean it worked pretty well in
in
the unanimous approach
and if we felt uh that
one we are now by now we have the
four members in our investment committee
two venture partners
and one i mean myself
make it the four and if one of those
four doesn't feel comfortable with the
investment we'll in most cases we'll
actually
skip it right now i cannot tell you that
that's the right approach or the bad one
but it worked for us i mean or
long i mean i think that overall almost
50 companies 5.0 by now
16 companies in the first one six exits
in the fact
in the first fund sixteen companies in
fan two
wow with uh two and a half exits
uh we are one of our companies just
announced a
spark merger back in january
amazing company called autonomou
and and the third fund which is a 2018
vintage
we invested so far in 13 companies so
for us i mean
almost 50 companies it worked uh pretty
well but
uh frankly i mean there are other
approaches as well
right no that makes a lot of sense and
you know eval one of the things that i
love
you know particularly about this show is
is you know tapping into the the inner
motivations
and and you know you're your partners
from what i understand
you know some of them chose you know
they they they weren't from you know
founders and entrepreneurs to the vc
world someone
back to the to the business world and in
the private you know
specific company what what what gets you
going
you know why why invest in
500 companies 50 companies you know why
go for the 51st
what is it about the 51st adventure
that makes you as excited to do it
because you
you know of all people know that it's
passion that drives to success very
often right and
and you you want to invest in passionate
people and you also want to be
passionate yourself
so where is that passion coming from
so i think the passion at least you know
from a personal point of view
is uh actually just curiosity of
knowing and learning new markets in most
cases
and that's what is a basically
fascinating in the vc industry
in most cases i would meet people that
are
clever than us know their domain much
better than us
right and actually can take you to and
and offer you to join their journeys so
i i always i mean i've been you know it
was a kind of of a
fascinating to see some of these
entrepreneurs
taking that are might you know maybe
expert in
in optics or other fields in
semiconductor in
in you know in cloud computing that
basically want to
change the world and for me i mean it
was kind of
learning a new industry a new market i
can share with you a few examples i mean
when
when we first invested in autonomous
kind
of the car data platform
we are very far from being experts in
the car industry
right but we failed i mean that when you
look at the technology that data
would be a big issue in that sector and
change that industry the same goes by
the way with the
more recent investment that we
made in a company called theater
the digital health arena so
i mean we're fascinated by by the
technology by the computer vision
technology there
and the fact that it can actually change
an industry in a sector that we are not
we are not familiar with
but the moment i mean you identify a
good technology
and you need to apply it to a sector
that is
kind of green field so that's that's the
passion i mean the passion is to to
join this journey very early to take it
from seed
to early sales and frankly i think that
after that stage there are many other
investors
i mean that can take the lead and i'm
pretty sure that
you you have participated in those
board meetings when company when
companies start selling
so very fast it becomes you know more
like
reporting on the on the quarterly
results
right and that's it so we are more
interested and i'm more interested in
really building the company from scratch
helping the founders
understanding by the way that we are the
co-pilot
yeah the pilot is the founder
we are here i mean to to give advice to
i mean not be because we are a smarter
because i've seen and i've been in those
situation
25 or 30 times while in most cases for
the founders or
group of founders it's the first time
for them
so we are trying to advise sometimes we
are successful
sometimes we are not but at the end
that's the founders show amazing
i want to thank you for being so kind
and generous to come on the show
i really appreciate it and i know how
busy you are i love
the the you know the curious the curious
nature
that you're bringing on to this and
you're saying yes you know
you could look at me as an investor you
can also just look at me as somebody
who's deeply curious about
different markets about meeting amazing
people and and being a co-pilot
of these different entrepreneurs who i
believe in
and and helping them you know figure out
you know
and through the trenches how to get to
this you know
point where you can turn your board
meetings into quarterly reports
versus uh versus you know the magical
work that you're doing there so thank
you for sharing with
me that i have the most important final
question i don't know if it's the most
important but it's the definitely the
final question
which is three words used to describe
yourself
never give up ah which basically
it's not only when it's it's described i
think uh
i would like to believe that you
describe me but it is five stage one as
well
i mean we've crossed uh many prices over
20 years
the fun would be to celebrate its 20th
anniversary this year wow and i've seen
three crisis
uh uh during that time and i remember in
the world i mean looked very pretty bad
and we said okay i mean it's gonna
improve
and we shouldn't give up on our
portfolio and uh
it goes you know the same in 2001 when
we really started
so basically i think that the motto here
is really never give up
thank you very very much stay safe and
stay healthy thank you for coming on
thank you and take care bye
[Music]
you